it's been a long time in the making yeah
I mean I went to uh Atlanta during the
pandemic and we kind of did like a
little generation now yep but yeah you
being here yeah it's about [__] time
I feel like I've been stalking you it
felt I mean well never that I mean
you're my guy it's like yo drum when you
coming on the [__] show you're in La
all the time yeah it has and I I have
been putting it off for some time but I
have reason to be here I got a [__]
new album new album I'm single you know
what I mean I wanted to be I wanted to
be timely and I knew a conversation with
you is is you know significant you know
what I'm saying for sure well I I do say
DJ Drama is the greatest hip-hop DJ of
all time it's big the greatest of all
time I'm not saying it's a scratching
and [__] transforming and [__] but
you're the greatest you're a goat so
hold on let me thank you first of all so
if they're making a
for 50 years of hip-hop and they make a
DJ list like of the greatest DJs in 50
years you're putting me I I don't even
think it's a disco gushing wow
I mean I it would be hard for me to
agree
um humbly
I would like to be in the top five but
if we're talking 50 years we're talking
Jazzy Jeff we talking no no no listen
I'm talking about listen because Jazzy
Jeff probably
like like there's guys who are really
good at DJing yeah party rockers [__]
I mean we can go on and there's like
something but I just think when I think
of like
your cultural impact on the last 20
years of rap music
it is literally not even a discussion
nobody has ever impacted hip-hop culture
as a DJ the way you have and I don't
even think and like listen you can go
back to cool herk was cool herc a DJ or
a rapper it was a DJ he was a DJ okay so
he kind of started it yeah but I'm
talking about bro I'm [__] 36. so
when I was coming up it was Funk Flex I
had like the 60 Minutes of Funk [__]
um I was getting DJ Clue tapes and then
when I started bootlegging [__] and
selling [__] at the Swap Meet it was
like all gangster girl [__] but we're
talking about your fingerprints are all
over
it all
cheesy Wayne Pharrell Gucci
you just want to [__] Grammy with
Tyler the Creator bruh you put a you won
a Grammy with a gangster grills what are
we talking about a gangster girls want a
Grammy
I've done some [__] man I'm really like
that I really think that like people can
say what they want like I mean people
there's been even artists there's been a
guy like listen DJ Khaled for sure has
put out bigger songs than you as an
artist right right
but like
I forget the name of the little Wayne DJ
Khaled tape but it wasn't that big of a
deal like it had it it had a gem on
there though but you remember which tape
I'm talking about yeah it was called the
[__] this The Re-Up the the suffix the
suffix the suffix the suffix yeah the
suffix but we're talking about the
dedication yeah yeah yeah we're talking
about dedication we're talking do you
just like I mean even like [__] like
little brothers Gangsta Grill like just
so many like your fingerprints are
everywhere like you just told me a story
about your first tape with Gucci
were you removed Nicki Minaj's verse
because she wasn't popping yet
oh God why are we talking about this
Nikki I apologize so what happened
um me and Gucci's first actual gangster
girls we actually did one with Yo Gotti
first it was called definition of a g
that was the first tape me and uh Gucci
had did together it was collaboration
Gotti Gucci and me the first official
Gucci Man gangster girls was called the
movie
and when he brought it to me the first
song that was for the tape the first
voice you heard on the S on the tape was
Nicki Minaj obviously this is a uh early
Nicki Minaj and
disrespectfully you know I felt like
we can't have a gangster girls with me
and Gucci and the first voice you hear
not be Gucci so I removed her
um perverse perverse from that song I
feel terrible to this day did she know
it was your decision
um
I don't know she she may know now but in
defense I will say that
I made sure out of everyone that Nicki
Minaj was on dedication three because
Nicki Minaj was about to get left off of
dedication three she was calling me
directly cedram please don't let the
tape come out without me on there and I
said I got you so Nicki Minaj is on
dedication three directly because I made
sure she was on there so so you got it
came back trying to make it up I'm
trying to you know did anyone ever hear
the Nikki verse that you remember did
you ever use it anywhere else with that
I don't I really don't know I don't know
whatever came from that we'd have to
probably ask Gucci do you still have
like your OG email access I wish I had a
gangster girls.com Gmail that was
probably just some [__] in there
so crazy I used to get these [__]
Beats
from this like random email from like it
was like boy idea or something like I
was like who is this boy idea sending me
all these beats like in like 0506 you
should flood my email because you know
how to pronounce the name it's a weird
name and now looking back why wasn't it
yeah it was Boy Wonder I've told him
that I've definitely we've talked about
that like [__] was crazy yeah cause I
just think about like even the last two
or three years the research like if you
think about it we went through this
weird cycle where the blogs would drop
the no DJ version of mixtapes as well as
the DJ versions of mixtapes and I
remember you having an issue with that
and
um I felt used yeah because they would
use the gangster girl's brand yeah to
like launch it and then like a week
later they would drop like a no DJ
version without your [__] on it yeah
like what the [__] but now we like kind
of like came back around now everybody
is getting the gangster grills and
they're dropping them on dsps like I
mean shots Perico you guys just dropped
that one
there was a day recently where I feel
like you had three tapes come out in one
day and one day I dropped gz snowfall
Snoop and NBA young boy that was crazy
like I was like on the I was like right
after I won DJ of the year or two with
the hip-hop Awards
I was like oh yeah I'm coming from
coming for the next year's award